الحوسبة المسؤولة تعني
تطوير الحوسبة الكمومية
مع إدراك قوتها
وتأثيراتها المحتملة، وحين نقول "مسؤولة"
نقصد تطوير التكنولوجيا واستخدامها
وفق مبادئ محددة مسبقًا لمساعدتنا على منع
الأضرار المحتملة والتخفيف منها
مع تعزيز حلول تكون بشكل استباقي
شاملة ومساءلة في IBM
دفعنا الإحساس بالمسؤولية
تجاه المجتمع منذ عقود، واليوم نصف أنفسنا بأننا محفّز
يجعل العالم يعمل بشكل أفضل، ما يعني أن علينا
مسؤولية النظر في تداعيات
التقنيات التي نبنيها ونساعد في تطبيقها
بينما نطور هذه التكنولوجيا الجديدة
القرارات التي نتخذها اليوم ستؤثر على المستقبل
وهذه القرارات
لديها القدرة على إحداث تأثير هائل على المجتمع
مثلًا، قد تضطر للاختيار بين متابعة تطبيق
يفيد عددًا قليلًا من أصحاب المصلحة أو
تطبيق قد يحل مشكلة مجتمعية
نأمل أن تتمكن أنت كعميل من التفكير
في التطوير المسؤول للحوسبة الكمومية
فالتفكير بمسؤولية يساعد شركتك على بناء الثقة
مع المستثمرين والمستهلكين
مع بناء سمعة من النزاهة
والإعجاب لدى موظفيك
وعملائك، وفي المقابل
يحميك من الصحافة السيئة والغرامات
والعقوبات. في هذا الفيديو
سنستعرض اعتبارات المسؤولية الهامة
للتحدث عنها مع فريقك
بينما تستكشف الحوسبة الكمومية
وتطبيقاتها، وحين يتعلق الأمر بالحوسبة الكمومية
فالتفكير والتصرف بمسؤولية
يعني اتباع مجموعة من المبادئ
والقيم لتوجيه تطويرك
ونشر التكنولوجيا
مثلًا، يعني هذا الشفافية
في القيود والقدرات على حد سواء
للحوسبة الكمومية اليوم. لدينا لغة
في عقودنا تلزم عملاء IBM Quantum
باستخدام أنظمتنا بمسؤولية
وألا يستخدموا أنظمتنا
لأغراض خبيثة أو غير قانونية
نسمي هذه بنود الاستخدام المسؤول
والاستخدام المقبول
هذه اللغة تؤثر بالفعل في كيفية تفكير عملائنا
في تطوير الكم
لحالات استخدامهم، ويمكننا
أيضًا المساعدة في توجيه مسار الحوسبة الكمومية
من خلال تحديد التطبيقات التي نسعى إليها
للتطوير والتسريع
وللحماية من الاستخدامات غير المسؤولة المحتملة
لتقنيتنا، طورنا أيضًا تقنية IBM Quantum
الآمنة القوية. بينما تفكر في كيفية
وسبب استخدام الحوسبة الكمومية
تأكد من الحديث بواقعية عن توقعاتك
للحوسبة الكمومية والجداول الزمنية
التي تأمل فيها دمج الكم
لا تقدم الحوسبة الكمومية
على أنها غامضة، بل حاول شرحها بشكل واقعي
كأجهزة حوسبة
تتبع قواعد فيزياء الكم
تأكد من أن حالة استخدامك للحوسبة الكمومية
شاملة باستباقية
وتأخذ بعين الاعتبار جميع أصحاب المصلحة المحتملين
لتحديد مدى
أي تأثيرات اجتماعية سلبية
تأكد من تحديد مبادئ واضحة
وقيم لاستكشاف حالة الاستخدام
وتطويرها. شكرًا
على مشاهدتك، ونأمل
وأنت تجلب الحوسبة الكمومية النافعة للعالم
ستفكر أيضًا في كيفية القيام بذلك بمسؤولية.
The the